[Music]
the Border battle Remains the biggest
media furer in Washington as a house
panel voted to impeach Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayorcas some
pundits on both sides say the
Republicans have the wrong target why
impeach mayorcas when the policies came
from Joe Biden Joe Biden is the one that
rescinded the policies of Donald Trump
with a stroke of a pen it is absurd that
you have again the impeachment of my
orcus
for not doing what Republicans are
refusing to do mayorcas has repeatedly
defended his handling of the Southern
border it is my testimony that the
border is secure and we are working
every day day and night to increase its
security the Partyline vote comes as the
Senate is trying to salvage a bipartisan
deal on the border after Donald Trump
urged Republicans not to pass it so
Jason even some media concern
conservatives are saying don't impeach
my Arcus what he's doing is carrying out
the boss's policies Joe Biden's policies
at the
border well but if you're going to come
to Congress and you're going to lie
about it you're going to go to the
American people and say the border is
secure there's no metric that supports
that there's somewhere between 45 and
85,000 unaccompanied miners
unaccompanied miners they came across
that border 8 yearolds 9year olds 10year
olds little boys and girls and this
Administration can't tell you where they
are they just released them out of the
Homeland to who knows who for sex
trafficking and other types of things
are you kidding me somebody's got to be
held accountable for that the Border can
be secure do what the border patrol
wants to do that's what's missing in
this whole equation they will not meet
with the border patrol okay it has been
since SE 2021 since they would meet with
the border patrol why not do what they
say Lucy I just want to acknowledge what
everybody knows the border is an
absolute disaster and Alejandro mayor
bear some of the responsibility but the
media point out there hasn't been a
cabinet officer impeached in 150 years
that was William bellnap 1876 and that
guy was accused of corruption so is this
a case of Republicans holding these
impeachment hearings to put a spotlight
on what will probably be their number
one campaign issue it's a case of
Republicans responding to the base that
has gone out of its mind and has lost
the thread and using tools that are not
meant for situations like like this over
genuine policy disagreements to try to
punish a political appointee and it's
not going to work but I just want to say
because I feel very passionate about
this spare me the idea that republicans
in Congress are impeaching my orcus or
taking aim at Joe Biden because they
care about unaccompanied miners at the
border that is just absolutely absurd
and if that is the case then they should
get with the program and get on board
with the bipartisan border bill has up
by MERS their own of their own dare how
dare you go ahead Jason don't tell me
that I don't care about these little
kids why not pass hr2 which actually
pass con I said Congressional
Republicans I respect I used to be in
Congress I was a chairman of a committee
in Congress working on this very issue
one a time one at a time
Jason
Jason I I worked on this issue I was in
Congress I was a chairman I was on the
immigration sub committee we started
highlighting the problems on the border
but you know what Joe Biden came in and
changed all of those policies with a
stroke of his pen so don't WR give me
this righteous indignation that
Republicans don't care about the kids if
the Democrats cared about the kids then
where are the 85,000 kids where are they
Lucy uh I'll let you respond in a second
but I also want you to take on this
which is since Donald Trump said this
will hurt Republicans don't do anything
right now wait till I get back in office
um the media are saying many are saying
he wants the issue but not a solution
but is that
fair Bingo Donald Trump does not want
immigration reform right now James
Langford a member of the Republican
Party a Republican senator himself
talked about how suddenly the appetite
for immigration reform has gone out the
window because Donald Trump who by the
way we as far as we know has not even
seen the text of the bill said this week
basically privately has been letting
members of Congress both on the the
Senate and the house side know that he
does not want them to take up
immigration reform because he is worried
that it will create Optics that are good
for Joe Biden that is has been reported
and vouched for by Republicans
Congressman I mean no disrespect to
you you are not a current member of
Congress I'm not imputing you at all it
is just the case that republicans in
Congress really seem to have lost their
appetite and I don't think that anyone
honestly believes and if so then we are
very very far a field here that
Democrats don't care about unaccompanied
minor children but if any if we all
agree we care about the children then
let's pass a bipartisan bill on
immigration and come to the table Jason
house Speaker Mike Johnson says the bill
is DOA and then he said well he did
consult with Donald Trump uh several
times about this uh thereby again giving
rise to this notion that this is
political in
nature the Republicans are opposed to
this including president Trump because
of the the content of the outlines that
have been released out there publicly
Republicans did pass a border Bill last
year it was M May of 2023 why don't the
Democrats take up that bill what if
they're so worried about immigration and
they say they need legislation which
they don't and by the way the the head
of the border patrol Union Brandon Jud
will tell you you don't need new
legislation you don't need more people
and you don't need more money you need
to enforce the current law with this
Administration is not doing out of time
but let me just add that Mike Johnson
also says uh that he's going to do a
standalone bill on military aid to
Israel leaving out Ukraine and I'm sure
that will set up another round of
battles uh Jason chaitz and Lucy cwell
thanks so much for joining us passionate
issue I understand